Speaker 1: This next clip is truly a pleasure
to watch and it is exactly what I have been
recommending be done when dealing with right
wing media.
Engage in conversation, but get them on the
record.
Did Trump win or lose in twenty twenty?
Let's start there just so we know who and
what we're dealing with here.
The Daily Beast reports that yesterday during
an appearance on Fox News I'm sorry, the day
before yesterday, Texas State Representative
James Talarico, a Democrat young guy, challenged
Pete Hegseth to tell his viewers that Donald
Trump lost the twenty 20 presidential election
to Joe Biden.
Seth refused to just confirm, yes, Trump lost,
which really proves the guests point in trying
to get him on the record about this.
And Talarico quickly started going after Fox
News.
He eventually demanded, Hey, Pete, say that
Trump lost.
Say it.
Let's take a look at it.
This is just fantastic.
Someone in your
Speaker 2: district that can't get ID, you
have made a lot of money personally and you've
enriched a lot of corporations with advertising
by getting on here and spewing lies and conspiracy
theories to folks who about my what I'm asking
you to do is tell your voters right now that
Donald Trump is the line that is, can you
resolve the lie that is the Democratic voter
ID?
It's not true.
But at least at least he was on the idea that.
Twenty, twenty.
Real quick, can you answer the question to
Donald Trump?
I think election running questions.
I'm not going to answer anything.
Speaker 1: So I think he I think they're meant
to say I'm asking questions, not answering
them.
But he seems so tripped up
Speaker 2: question for you know, it's just
my question is, why are you in Washington,
D.C. and not in
Speaker 1: someone?
He's in Washington, D.C., because Texas Republicans
threatened Texas Democrats with arrest, with
arrest if they didn't show up in order to
prevent a quorum, in order to prevent a disgusting
Texas voter suppression bill from passing.
But as far as the clip goes, I just absolutely
love that every Democratic guest should be
doing that every time they appear on these
networks.
But but.
Oh, but David, sir, they're not being brought
on to talk about whether Trump won.
So it's sandbagging.
It's wrong for them to do.
I don't care.
Make them kick you off.
Make them never invite you back.
If every single Democratic guest starts asking
this, it's going to very quickly put them
in a really awkward position.
But like I've been saying.
Do this in every interview with Republican
officials as well, when whoever on whatever
channel interviews a Republican official,
ask them just for context.
Did Donald Trump win or lose the 20 20 election?
And many of them have figured out how to play
coy.
Many of them, you say, did Trump win the election
or did Trump lose the election?
And they will say, listen, Joe Biden is the
president of the United States.
That's what matters.
Because what they're what they're avoiding
answering is whether Joe Biden should be based
on the election results.
That's how they play coy with it.
And so even asking the question, the host
still is going to have to be prepared.
But I think that this is an important thing
to do, because at the end of the day, what's
the point of interviewing people when they
can't even be on the same page about basic
facts?
Would we trust them about any of their views
on politics if they can't even acknowledge
who won the 20 20 election?
Think about it.
Analogously, if we did a series on space travel
and I suspect that a guest believe the earth
was flat and I start the interview by saying,
is the earth flat or spherical?
And they won't answer.
Why would I keep talking about space travel
with that person and the interview they can't
have we can't even get to a simple foundational
infrastructure about just the fundamentals
of how the world works.
Why would I continue talking about space travel?
And similarly, in political interviews, do
you accept that Donald Trump genuinely not
because of fraud or fraud, just he just lost?
If you don't accept that, why are we going
to talk to you about your views on politics?
It's a simple screening question.
Really nicely done by James Talarico.
I hope I hope that this becomes a trend where
Democratic guests will say this to right wing
hosts and hosts will act.
Ask Republican guests, did Trump win or did
Trump lose?
Answer that question before we move on.
I would love to see it.
And we'll have more on the strategy on The
David Pakman Show Instagram, which you can
find at The David Pakman Show.
This is crazy, but nearly 100000 followers
on The David Pakman Show Instagram will take
a quick break and be back with much
more
after this.